the movie begins with a few teenagers
sitting around a table at a house party
the Hot Topic is how to burn calories
and stay fit one of them brings out her
phone and shows an app saying it's
extremely effective this makes everyone
curious but when a girl tries to find it
she comes across a different app with a
similar title countdown on reading the
description of the app she finds that it
can foretell the exact time of a
person's death down to the last second
intrigued the group decides to turn the
app into a drinking game but one girl
named Courtney is reluctant however when
everyone insists she hesitantly
downloads the app and accepts the terms
and conditions afterwards everyone in
the group gets roughly 20 to 70 years
except Courtney who has only three hours
to live but none of them take it
seriously and make her drink all the
beer as per the game's rules you gonna
die Courtney now where up and poison
yourself just then her boyfriend Evan
shows up and helps her with the drinks
he gets so wasted that he is barely able
to drive but he's going to anyway so
after the party is over Courtney ditches
him and decides to walk home alone along
the way she gets a cryptic message from
the app saying she has broken the user
agreement she then notices a figure
following her from behind prompting her
to walk faster suddenly the app gives
out a notification mentioning that she
has no more than two minutes to live
terrified Courtney switches off the
phone and runs into her house she heads
straight to the bathroom to calm herself
down but things get even weirder she
hears a curtain move and when she turns
around an unseen Force takes a hold of
her and hurls her up towards the ceiling
the mobile phone is also miraculously
turned on and when the countdown reaches
zero Courtney is thrown to the bathroom
floor in a lifeless State elsewhere we
see that Evan's car has met with a
horrible accident he didn't download the
app he's just an idiot the seat in which
Courtney was supposed to be in is
impaled by a tree log the scene then
cuts to a hospital where a nurse named
Quinn is delivering food to the patients
when she learns that one of them is
missing She searches around the hospital
until she finds the patient in the
balcony area he is revealed to be none
other than Evan Quinn sits with him and
tries to relax him for his surgery the
next day however Evan is still
traumatized by what happened with his
girlfriend he explains to Quinn what the
countdown app is which says that he has
only 19 hours left to live he also tells
her about his girlfriend Courtney and
how she died Evan believes that he will
also die in the given time which happens
to coincide with his surgery however
Quinn who does not believe in all this
convinces him that everything will be
fine on the way back she bumps into a
senior Nurse Amy who asks Quinn to come
with her the hospital staff then
surprise her with a cake as it turns out
that Quinn is now a registered nurse
later she gets a notification on her
phone which turns out to be an ad for
the countdown app without thinking twice
she downloads the app and agree trees to
the terms and conditions it mentions
that she only has two days to live but
Quinn shrugs it off thinking the app is
a joke as she enters the left a senior
doctor Sullivan tries to flirt with her
however Quinn rudely rejects him before
leaving hell yeah Quinn the same night
Quinn has trouble completing her nursing
documents so she calls her friend for
help the latter says that she needs a
birth certificate to fill out the form
the scene then cuts to Quinn going to
her parents house to retrieve her birth
certificate after a bit of searching she
finds it in her late mother's room just
then Quinn hears a sudden noise from the
closet and when she goes to inspect she
finds her little sister Jordan hiding
with her boyfriend the guy immediately
leaves while Quinn is left in disbelief
about what she just saw however Jordan
is enraged that her romantic moment was
spoiled she never wanted Jordan to come
out of the closet she shouts at her
sister for always being away even after
the death of their mother once she
leaves Quinn is greeted by her father he
inquires if she wants to come and visit
their mother's grave sometime to which
she agrees the following day Evan is
being prepared for his surgery but he is
reluctant as the app says that he only
has three minutes left so he ditches his
surgery and leaves the room but right
then the app sends out a notification
saying he has broken the user agreement
the next second Evan sees a tall black
figure behind him in the mirror but
doesn't find anyone there in real time
the deathly figure then follows him to a
dark staircase Evan uses the flashlight
on his phone and nervously navigates the
place when he looks up he suddenly sees
a figure in Courtney's clothes it grabs
him and Chucks him down the staircase
right as the countdown reaches zero
shortly after Quinn arrives at work
where Amy informs her about the incident
disturbing her to get more information
she steals Evan's phone but realizes
that she needs a fingerprint to unlock
it left with no option Quinn heads to
the hospital Mortuary there she tries to
use Evan's finger but it doesn't work
hence she opens his eyes and finally
unlocks the phone using face recognition
as Quinn goes through his phone she
notices the countdown which has reached
zero later she realizes that her
countdown time is at the same hour she
will meet her dad and Jordan to go to
her mother's grave so she calls her dad
and immediately cancels her plans as
expected the app says that she has
broken the user agreement and suddenly
Quinn sees a dark figure in the room to
her relief it is only Dr Sullivan who
has come to ask her help with a patient
and probably to hit on her again the
same night Quinn tries her best to
delete the app but to no avail hence she
surfs the internet for Solutions she
comes across different cases about the
countdown app which only aggravates her
worries as she prepares to sleep she
suddenly sees a dead Evan on her bed fed
up she throws her phone to the ground
shattering it completely but despite
this it still shows the countdown this
terrifies Quinn deeply so she heads out
to her car and falls asleep there in the
morning Jordan wakes her up and the two
of them go to Quinn's apartment Jordan
wants to spend some time with her sister
but when Quinn refuses stating that it
isn't safe she gets angry and storms off
later Quinn goes to an electronic shop
and buys a new phone she becomes
relieved to find that the app isn't
there however when she is about to leave
she gets a notification from the
countdown app on her new phone Quinn
frantically asks the shopkeeper to
delete it but he is unable to do so
frustrated she gets into her car while A
customer from the store named Matt asks
the shopkeeper about the app Quinn was
talking about meanwhile as she is
driving Quinn suddenly sees a dark
figure causing her to Ram her vehicle
into another the angry owner of the car
is about to beat her up but just then
Matt comes outside and saves her ass he
then reveals that he too is suffering
because of the countdown app to discuss
it further the two enter a bar and think
of a way to read the terms and
conditions of the app they learn that it
only pops up when the app is freshly
installed so Matt convinces a drunk guy
to download countdown when he reaches
the terms and conditions page Quinn
starts reading them they state that the
players have to accept their Fates no
matter what despite the ominous warning
the drunk guy accepts and to everyone's
surprise he has a long countdown of 39
nine years meanwhile thinking that
demons are involved Quinn and Matt go to
the hospital to talk to the priest
however he tells them to visit someone
much more qualified and gives them an
address as they are about to leave Quinn
is called by Amy while Matt goes to the
bathroom there he sees a Barefoot child
from beneath the stall but doesn't pay
much attention to it afterwards his
mouth washes his hands he hears someone
crying when he goes to check he sees the
same kid walking through the Stalls as
if there is nothing in between soon the
light goes out and a mysterious figure
attacks him from behind Matt struggles
for his life but the next second the
lights come back on and the demon is
nowhere to be seen meanwhile Quinn heads
to a meeting with HR along with Dr
Sullivan it turns out the Pervert doctor
lied to HR saying he is the subject of
continuous assault by Quinn the latter
tries to assert that she is innocent but
the HR department suspends her for an
indefinite amount of time enraged Quinn
storms out of the room and meets Matt
who is still shaken by the earlier
incident shortly after they arrive at a
church and meet the man that the priest
pointed them towards after hearing them
out he recalls an ancient story where a
similar demon had terrorized a village
however after the people United and got
to know of its weakness they killed it
forever until now it's in an app now now
the priest wants to get a better idea of
how the app works so he tells Quinn and
Matt to find someone who can hack the
app in the next scene the two go to the
same mobile shop and ask the shopkeeper
for help the latter thinks that it is a
joke but when they offer him a decent
amount of money he agrees later the
shopkeeper hacks into the app and
uncovers the code which is in Latin he
also finds the countdown clocks for all
the users and changes the parameters
increasing their lifespans surprisingly
Jordan's name is also displayed there
revealing that she too has downloaded
that app following the successful
hacking operation Quinn takes Matt home
and she is too scared to spend the night
alone they have a short conversation
about their lives and soon fall asleep
at midnight Quinn suddenly wakes up
after hearing something outside the room
to her horror Matt is the one outside
meaning the person in bed with her is
the demon she freaks out and when Matt
takes off the bed sheets the demon
disappears unfortunately both mats and
Quinn's countdown goes back to their
original numbers elsewhere Jordan hears
her phone ring in another room and goes
to get it when she notices the countdown
suddenly the lights start to Flicker and
she hears her dead mom talking and the
very next second the woman appears
Jordan almost has a heart attack and
runs for her life and luckily Quinn and
Matt arrive in the nick of time and
rescue her after this the trio heads to
the priest there he deduces from the app
code that a curse has been put on them
yeah the code told me that the priest
then explains that in order to lift the
curse someone with the countdown app has
to either die early or live longer than
the countdown as expected they choose
the second option and the priest decides
to help them out He blesses some salt
before making a holy Circle to keep them
safe from the diamonds sir this is
actually pretty cool after the procedure
is complete Matt finds out he has only
two minutes left on the clock so he
steps aside for a second Quinn
accompanies him to console him but they
end up sharing an emotional kiss all of
a sudden the lights go out and all of
them Rush inside the circle the demon
appears shortly after and as planned it
cannot enter the circle they won this
round of salt paper app demons suddenly
Matt's phone starts to blare and he
begins to see visions of his dead
brother who manipulates him out of the
circle the demon then immediately pulls
him outside the building and Quinn runs
after him but when the two reunite Matt
is abruptly run over by a car and killed
devastated Quinn returns to the house
only to find her sister bleeding from an
apparent cut so she immediately rushes
Jordan to the hospital there Quinn is
approached by another nurse who reveals
that she too is a victim of Dr
Sullivan's abuse she wishes that someone
kills him in a gruesome manner hearing
this Quinn gets a brilliant idea since
Sullivan also has the app she plans to
kill him prematurely hoping that it will
lift the curse later Quinn manages to
seduce him in his office and tells him
to follow her to the closed section of
the hospital once Sullivan falls into
her trap she attempts to inject him with
a ton of morphine but right then Jordan
arrives there looking for her suddenly
the doctor is dragged Away by the demon
to stop the premature killing Quinn goes
after them while Jordan checks her phone
which reveals that she only has two
minutes left to live meanwhile Quinn
finds Sullivan and is about to attack
him but the demon pushes her away
allowing the doctor to escape after a
while the demon starts chasing after
Jordan just as her time is about to run
out Quinn confronts it with a syringe
pushed against her skin the demon
impersonates her dead mother but Quinn
is not faced she bravely injects herself
with the morphine killing her on the
spot because she died before her
countdown ended the curse is lifted and
the demon is seemingly vanquished
meanwhile Jordan rushes to Quinn's dead
body and surprisingly finds a drug
written on her arm with a bottle and
syringe in her pocket without wasting
any time Jordan uses the syringe and
injects it into Quinn's arm bringing her
back to life the scene then cuts to
sometime in the future where Quinn
Jordan and her dad pay respects to their
mother's grave the movie ends as Quinn
gets a notification on her phone which
says that the latest version of the
countdown app has been installed
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching